we're going to that party okay  definitely it's going to be incredible  they said two o'clock so I am or PM hi  hey hi what are you guys doing tonight  you guys should come back  well what friend is a second  we like you guys you might be club  material this club is exclusive each and  every member dominates his field you're  at the doorway to the elite so you ready  to play over the next 48 hours you will  be tested physically mentally  emotionally privilege comes with hard  work sacrifice  this is part of tradition what does this  have to do with the club we're looking  for your breaking point because great  men don't have one you can't keep doing  this for 48 hours it's just easy  Kev's roof rats do it come on man that  door there's you two college students  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  college guys am i right  you